hier kommt zu einem anderen fall und
zwar sie kennen das auch da sitzt man
vom telefon plötzlich kommt ein anruf
eine freundliche stimme sagt ich habe
hier ein bombastisches angebot wie wäre
es vielleicht mit einem abo macht auch
noch versprechungen und ich habe den
eindruck das ist jetzt wirklich ein
super super angebot und genau das ist
daniel großjohann aus berlin passiert
und er hat es zum video geschickt montag
ich wurde von einer firma namens pvz in
bremen angerufen und habe die
information bekommen dass ich ein gewinn
oder 500 euro gewonnen habe und in dem
telefonat geht es dann so weiter und wir
haben uns ein bisschen unterhalten
diese frau lena ja ich habe mir auch ein
paar sachen aufgeschrieben sagte auch
extra zu mir
schreiben sie mich mein schreiben sie
meinen namen auf das ist alles schon
alles sicher und eine woche später habe
ich keinen gewinn erhalten sondern ein
abo von der motorsport aktuell und bin
jetzt aktuell widerrufsrecht also hab
jetzt via website und per post noch mal
geschrieben dass sich das nicht
abgeschlossen habe und dass wieder rufe
ich habe bisher aber noch keine
informationen bekommen ob es bestätigt
ist ob es angekommen ist oder ob
irgendein anderes sagt ja was kann ich
machen und was kann ich machen damit ich
halt nicht irgendwie wieder angerufen
werden oder wie kommt man da aus habe
ich da jetzt schon vertrag abgeschlossen
ist da irgendwas anderes jetzt noch
kommt dann noch einmal bei dem brief
stand auch noch mal drin dass ich
irgendwie noch eine versicherung
abgeschlossen habe aber noch keine
bestätigung von der versicherung
bekommen haben das ist dass ich da auch
noch widerrufen kann ja na also aufgrund
des vertrauens züge den gläubigen
telefonats habe ich natürlich auch sagt
ja ok
cool ich freue mich dass ich den 500
euro geschenkt bekommen habe oder wo man
habe das ganze übrigens wurde war durch
wurde publiziert in oder wurde
verbreitet diese auch instagram in den
stories und das war angeblich konnte man
da beim balea gewinnspiel mitmachen habe
ich natürlich mitgemacht und jack ist
natürlich muss man natürlich auch die
nummer telefonnummer angeben
und dann habe ich den anruf bekommen
da steckt ja so einiges drin wahnsinn
der anruf das versprechen mal eben 500
euro ab zu sagen ja dann überlasse ich
ihnen herr kempkens das feld da gibt es
glaube ich einiges zu besprechen
ich musste mir tatsächlich einige
notizen machen weil der fall sozusagen
ganz interessant ist weil er aus
verschiedenen ebenen besteht also erst
mal haben wir diesen gewinn fällt diese
gewinn versprechens ebene
wir hatten immer so über jahre gab es
immer dass die haushalte tyrannisiert
worden mit gewinnversprechen und weil
das immer total ätzend war das hinter
irgendwie wieder los zu werden oder das
durchzusetzen gab es eine
gesetzesänderung für ein jahr vor
einigen jahren einen gewinn versprechen
muss eingehalten werden das heißt ein
gewinnversprechen macht einen klappbaren
anspruch das heißt wenn hier ein gewinn
versprochen wurde 500 euro man kann das
in irgendeiner form nachweisen kann man
das sogar einklagen punkt 1.2 mündliche
verträge mündliche verträge sind ohne
weiteres möglich nur testamente
eheverträge es gibt es ein paar verträge
die man eben nicht mündlich schließen
kann sondern die bedürfen einer gewissen
form schriftform sogar notarieller form
in einigen fällen aber die allermeisten
verträge können mündlich geschlossen
werden also wenn ich sie jetzt frage
wollen sie mal ein auto kaufen und sie
sagen ja ist im grunde genommen
kaufvertrag zustande gekommen aber das
besondere ist wir haben hier über
telekommunikationsmittel wir arbeiten ja
auch
gerade über übertragungstechnik und wenn
wir jetzt so einen vertrag schließen
würden unter verbrauchern dann ist der
widerruf war innerhalb von zwei wochen
über diese über das fernabsatz einheit
teil des bürgerlichen gesetzbuches weil
er eben über telekommunikationsmittel
zustande gekommen ist und da habe ich
ein widerrufsrecht das widerrufsrecht
beginnt mit ordnungsgemäßer belehrung
wir haben aber bei zeitschriften kein
widerrufsrecht haben wir einen
besonderen ausschluss das heißt
zeitschriften verträge kann ich endlich
schließen am telefon und habe kein
widerrufsrecht ist also eine total
ärgerliche situation aber hier wird es
darauf ankommen ob überhaupt ein vertrag
zustande gekommen ist denn nur dadurch
dass ich über widerruf spreche heißt das
noch lange nicht dass ein vertrag
zustande gekommen ist vertrag mir bietet
jemand eine zeitung an und ich sage ja
und der jene der sich darauf beruft muss
das nachweisen das heißt ich als
verbraucher bin erster in der
komfortablen situation kann abwarten
dann muss mir den vertrag nachweisen und
hier würden wir das geschildert bekommen
haben ist ja offenbar jemand bedruckt
worden daher wird versucht zu betrügen
da kann man auch strafanzeige zur
staatsanwaltschaft erstatten aber
wollten es doch nochmal aufdröseln gegen
einen zeitungs und zeitschriften abo ist
ja erstmal überhaupt nichts dagegen zu
sagen das kann ja auch wirklich sehr
viel spaß machen aber es wird natürlich
das vertrauen erschlichen und die
aufmerksamkeit natürlich konzentriert in
dem ich erst mal mit einem
gewinnversprechen konfrontiert wenn
sonst hätte ich vielleicht
möglicherweise gleich aufgelegt aber
wenn es natürlich darum gewinne gibt er
geht dann bin ich natürlich hellwach und
höhere dieser dame dann auch zu das ist
so und das ist genau auch so wenn das so
in dieser form praktiziert wird teil der
betrügerische masche wenn man jetzt
nicht den gewinn bekommt aber ich
persönlich kenne aus reinem aus meiner
praxis keinen einzigen fall wo jemand
tatsächlich so einen gewinn dann auch
bekommen hätte der am telefon angeboten
wird 500 euro so etwas gewonnen dann
freut man sich natürlich ich kenne nicht
einen fall wo das wirklich auch passiert
ist ich kenne nur die fälle wo das eben
in die hose gegangen ist und dann kann
man natürlich diese verträge die
zeitschriften verträge kann man ohne
weiteres abschließen wenn man das will
selbstverständlich wenn man die
zeitschrift gerne haben möchte jederzeit
machen das ist auch gut so dass das
telefonisch eben geht aber es gibt dann
eben dieses widerrufsrecht nicht und das
macht die sache dann etwas problematisch
das sind ja schwierigkeiten beim vertrag
gibt also ich glaube wir müssen uns dem
fall mal an nehmen hier ist auch ein
firmenname gefallen und der zuschauer
hat sich auch alles notiert also wir
können das relativ schnell
nachvollziehen und ich bin mal gespannt
was die firma dazu sagt also demnächst
in dieser sendung mehr